Salut ! Dans cette 16ème vidéo des énigmes de l'été
puisqu'on en fait 32 donc on est en plein milieu.
Je vous donne une nouvelle énigme, bien sûr c'est le concept de cette série, mais surtout la réponse à l'énigme d'hier.
C'était pas vraiment une énigme hier. On avait dit c'est un peu de la survie.
Comment faire pour trouver à coup sûr la sortie d'un labyrinthe ?
Il suffit de plaquer sa main sur le mur de gauche ou sur le mur de droite, et de le suivre sans jamais lâcher la main du mur.
Nécessairement même si il y a un cul-de-sac, ça va vous faire longer toujours  le même mur
et vous allez forcément, que ce soit celui de gauche ou de droite, trouver la sortie grâce à ça.
Et si un jour, vous êtes enfermé dans un labyrinthe, vous penserez à moi.
Alors que la situation de l'énigme d'aujourd'hui, ça, je ne pense pas non plus que vous alliez le vivre...
Alors c'est vrai, l'énigme d'aujourd'hui aussi elle est connue.
D'ailleurs, on en a déjà parlé dans des commentaires d'autres vidéos.
Et c'est justement comme ça que je me suis rendu compte qu'il y a pleins de personnes qui ne la connaissaient pas.
Donc ce n'est pas moi qui l'ai écrite, c'est une énigme populaire, qu'est vraiment connue.
Imaginez sur le bord d'une rivière, il y a un homme qui est sur la rive.
Il a sa barque qui flotte et il a avec lui, un chou, un lapin, et un loup.
Pourquoi ce mec là a un chou, un lapin et un loup ?
J'en sais rien !
En tout cas, il doit leur faire traverser la rivière, mais il ne peut prendre qu'un des trois à la fois.
C'est-à-dire que si il prend le chou, il laisse les deux autres sur la rive.
Il ne peut pas mettre plus d'un élément dans sa barque.
Sur le principe, je me dis qu'elle doit être quand même assez mal foutue sa barque...
Parce que bon, si tu prends le lapin là...
le chou là...
Bon... il y a moyen de se débrouiller.
Lui il peut pas !
De toute manière, sinon, il n'y aurait pas d'énigme.
Il faut savoir par contre, qu'il ne peut pas laisser le lapin et le chou tout seul.
Sinon le lapin mange le chou.
Il peut pas laisser non plus le renard et le lapin tout seul, sinon le renard bouffe le lapin.
Mais heureusement pour nous, le chou ne mange pas le renard.
Ma question est: Quand on prend en compte tous ces éléments, comment va faire l'homme et sa barque, pour faire traverser les trois sur l'autre rive ?
Comment il va se débrouiller pour qu'à la fin, les trois et lui même soient sur l'autre rive ?
Et non, il n'a pas le droit de jeter le lapin comme un ballon ! *rires*
En utilisant la barque à chaque fois.
Cherchez bien, ne donnez pas la réponse dans les commentaires.
Je suis sûr qu'il y en a pleins qui la connaissent.
Si vous la connaissez, mettez juste "Je connaissais"
Mettez un pouce en l'air pour qu'on sache le nombre de personnes qui connaissent la réponse ou qui ont trouvé la réponse.
Et moi je vous la donnerai demain matin à 11H.
Profitez bien de votre samedi, du soleil, de la plage.
Sortez, faites la fête, amusez vous !
Pensez quand même à vous abonner avant de partir.
Et rendez-vous demain à 11H.
Ciao !